[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia vamos a hablar de los tests
las pruebas que se hacen para detectar
los contagios del coronavirus en
especial una variedad las pruebas de
antígeno bienvenido doctor pérez a
france 24 empiezo por preguntarle
durante todos estos meses se ha
insistido mucho en confinamientos
distancia social uso apropiado de
tapabocas para combatir la pandemia de
kobe 19 pero las pruebas son igualmente
importantes para enfrentarla porque
es muy importante que entendamos
valentina que es necesario aislar a las
personas que portan el virus no
necesariamente son sintomáticas y si son
sintomáticas que tengan el coronavirus
estas pruebas cada vez son más fáciles
de hacer para poder detectar que estas
personas enfermas se aíslen
efectivamente con su grupo familiar y
así podemos establecer los aislamientos
selectivos y poder contener para que
haya evitado evitar la transmisibilidad
en la comunidad explíquenos sobre las
distintas pruebas que se están haciendo
la pcr los antígenos las ventajas y las
desventajas que tiene cada una
las dos pruebas de pcr anti genios se
toman por hisopado nasofaríngeo una de
ellas se procesa por biología molecular
la que hacemos desde el principio de la
pandemia su tiempo de respuesta
generalmente uno o dos días tres días y
es una prueba que es muy sencillo es
decir que detecta muchas personas
enfermas la prueba antígenos es una
prueba que se hace en 15 ó 20 minutos el
resultado sale en menos de una hora
tiene una sensibilidad un poco menor
pero también es igualmente importante
cuando estamos hablando de comunidad y
personas sintomáticas es rápida es
efectiva es segura y nos da información
valiosa doctor aunque la efectividad de
las pruebas de antígeno podría ser menor
pues arroja un porcentaje significativo
de falsos positivos o negativos hay
reportes de que muchos países están
haciendo masivamente pues son más
baratas y rápidas y contribuyen al
monitoreo del contagio esto es así
sin las plagas de antígenos son las que
se utilizan no para diagnóstico clínico
sino para testers masivos en personas
que tienen síntomas y hace que sea más
fácil tomar la decisión del aislamiento
tienen problemas como cualquier prueba
no es perfecta pero si se hace una
evaluación clínica si se hace entre una
estrategia de contención y si se hace
con la metodología nos va a ayudar
muchísimo porque el resultado es en una
hora es mucho más fácil llevar la prueba
de la comunidad que lo que la comunidad
venga hacia la prueba la ventaja de los
antígenos es que va hacia la comunidad
doctor en nuestros países en américa
latina' una prueba pcr puede tener un
costo casi imposible de pagar para
muchísimas personas en ese sentido las
pruebas de antígeno pueden ser una
alternativa para contribuir a masificar
este testeo
ha pasado lo siguiente las pruebas de
pcr también han reducido el costo sin
embargo las palas de antígenos son dos o
tres veces más baratas que una prueba de
pcr más rápida no son mejores eso es
claro pero son útiles claro dar mayor
accesibilidad da oportunidade mayor
estrés de almácigos y es mucho más
excesiva el sistema de salud por eso las
palentinas también son valiosas y parte
importante del control de la pandemia le
pregunta también con la llegada de la
vacuna esto parece la esperanza mayor
para poder combatir la pandemia pero
sigue siendo importante hacer estas
pruebas
y como lo dijo valentina al principio no
solamente las pruebas en el alejamiento
físico la higiene de manos la
ventilación de los espacios son
fundamentales la mejor vacuna es que no
nos de coronavirus las es hacerse la
prueba llevar a hacer la prueba
solicitar la prueba
hace parte de la estrategia para saber
qué personas van a ser susceptibles de
la vacuna inicialmente que personas se
priorizan quienes tenemos con la
enfermedad a quienes las resolvemos es
decir que las que las hacen parte
también de la estrategia pre vacuna y
para poder controlar la pandemia en
forma exitosa doctor si estas pruebas
son tan importantes porque hay muchos
países donde ya no se le requieren a los
viajeros y hay otras otras naciones que
están considerando retirarlas la
dinámica de la pandemia es distinta en
cada uno de los países no es tanta veces
la circulación que ya da lo mismo si hay
o no en migración de personas y por qué
se hagan la prueba sin embargo en
algunos países donde se están logrando
efectivamente la mitigación puede ser
parte de la estrategia disminuir el
número de personas positivas y hacer los
tests
sin embargo esos son designaciones
individuales de cada país y de cada
realidad epidemiológica pues doctor
pérez muchísimas gracias por todas estas
respuestas y a ustedes gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con nosotros aquí
en france 24
[Música]